for the first time ever 50.1 percent of
women are childless by 30. there are
more women without children at 30 than
there are women with children what our
society does to 19 year old women we
just lie to them all the time there's
nothing more important than your career
there will be nothing more important to
you in your life than your career there
should be nothing more important in your
life than your career implicit in that
is the idea that children are a burden
and the idea that women should have
children is part of the oppressive
patriarchy i've worked in female
dominated occupations my entire life i
never experienced the world except as
that and so i've watched women progress
through their professional careers at
every level of attainment from the
lowest to the highest relatively
bias-free what i've seen is that as
women progress towards their late 20s
there's a psychological transformation
and they place less emphasis on their
career and way more emphasis
particularly on having a child and that
really reaches a crisis point around 29
or 30 for the vast majority of women and
their attitude flips